♪♪♪
>>> DANG, CHARLISE YOU LOOK
AMAZING IN THOSE JEANS,
AND YOU SMELL GREAT, TOO.
WHAT'S YOUR SECRET?
>> WHY, THEY'RE MY ASS ANGEL
PERFUME JEANS OF COURSE.
>> PERFUME JEANS?
OOH, GORGEOUS.
CAN I GET A PAIR?
>> SWEET SMELLING BOOTY.
THESE JEANS ARE FROM HEAVEN
ABOVE.
♪ SHE'S GOT THE ASS OF AN ANGEL
AND NOW SHE SMELLS LIKE ONE
TOO ♪
♪ SHE'S GOT THE ASS OF AN ANGEL
YOU CAN SMELL THAT IT'S TRUE ♪
>> ASS ANGEL JEANS ARE THE ONLY
JEANS THAT COVER YOUR SECRET
LADY SCENTS.
DON'T WORRY, GIRL.
ALL I CAN SMELL IS CINNAMON
SUGAR SWIRL.
>> HE KNOWS THE BOOTY LOOK LIKE
CAKE, BUT NOW IT SMELLS LIKE ONE
TOO.
>> BLOW OUT THE CANDLES AND TAKE
A BITE.
♪ PERFUMED AROMA AND I'M
TALKING BACK DOOR ♪
♪ SHE'S GOT THE ASS OF AN
ANGEL ♪
♪ WANT TO SMELL IT SOME MORE ♪
>> ASS ANGEL PERFUME JEANS ARE
ALSO MADE OF LAVENDER, ROSE,
AND LOADS OF AWESOME INDUSTRIAL
CHEMICALS.
>> THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF SMELL.
I GOT TO SIT DOWN.
>> OH, NO, NOT ON THE FURNITURE.
>> OH, WOW, MY BUTT -- THE SEAT.
>> THAT'S THE MAGIC OF THE
JEANS, OF COURSE.
>>HEY, I WENT TO THE BATHROOM
EARLIER AND IT STUNG WHEN I
TINKLED.
IS THAT THE JEANS?
>> UH-HUH.
DO NOT WEAR THESE JEANS IF YOU
HAVE KIDNEY OR LIVER PROBLEMS.
>> SMELLING GOOD, LADIES.
WOW.
THAT ASS IS HOT.
>> AND SO MY FRONT.
>> NOW IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME,
I HAVE TO GO SING.
♪ DO THEY WEAR JEANS
IN HEAVEN? ♪
♪ THAT ASS OF MY PRAYERS ♪
>> ASS ANGEL JEANS.
CONSULT YOUR DOCTOR BEFORE
PURCHASING.